[Music]
this is a power struggle and right now
corporations control all the power
when Enough stars align when enough bad
things happen all at once that the food
system is at risk we will know it and
the pain will be acute
I really couldn't think of responsible
and effective ways to mitigate those
risks short of Reinventing the food
system if there's any upside to covid
it's that everyone in this country
experienced the downside of the hyper
globalization regime the system that the
monopolists had built was built to fail
it was built to break
control your money you control your
destiny the one thing that I would love
to see is for government and policies to
be shaped around people
this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
globalization as we've known it for the
last 40 years has failed hyper-efficient
systems were designed to drive down the
costs of goods and services but covid
and the war in Ukraine showed the
vulnerability of our supply chains
and now real people and policy makers
alike are rethinking what those should
look like
in this film we're going to look at
globalization and its impact on Farming
and food
nothing is more crucial than Agriculture
and yet crops like these have become
Commodities with a handful of global
companies controlling everything from
meat processing to grain production all
around us you see cash crops like corn
for example most of which is grown not
to feed people but to feed cattle that
contribute to Global emissions obesity
and other systemic problems
I want to show you why cheap food which
is what the system is designed to
produce isn't cheap when you count the
cost to people the planet and our food
security
and what some of the solutions might be
in a deglobalizing world
so I grew up in rural Indiana and I feel
really at home on the farm but I do
think that farming in America is
changing it's at a pivot point and so I
wanted to take a road trip and really
understand and meet the farmers the
people the policy makers the communities
that are part of this change
oh
we travel through Iowa the biggest corn
producing state in the U.S and for the
most part this is how farming looks in
the U.S endless rows of corn and soy but
I was heading further south to Missouri
because I wanted to meet some farmers
who were trying to do things differently
these Farmers have a long history with
the land and they see the future in
sustainable Community focused farming
I'm Joe Maxwell I'm the president and
co-founder of farm action the Maxwell
family came in and covered wagons and
settled a large part of this region the
Farms have been in the family for over
100 years my name is Chelsea Davis I'm
the owner of The Root Cellar which is
the local food Hub located in Columbia
Missouri something that's really
important to me is making sure that
family Farmers have a voice I was a cook
in the military
and the one time everybody gets together
is at the child line nothing brings
people together like good food
[Music]
there's not a lot of Diversified Farms
left across the countryside but we raise
corn soybeans wheat some alfalfa and
then we have Livestock on this Farm we
have sheep you grew up in Indiana unlike
on most U.S Farms Joe isn't locked into
a contract to sell his corn to a big
grain Corporation he tells me that he
uses manure for my neighbor's cattle
farm rather than just chemical
fertilizers that's a resilient local
supply chain right there
now all of us unfortunately are
beginning to get more and more squeezed
and we're really farming more and more
for what the government subsidies are
Joe says deregulation means that the big
corporations who buy the crops have all
the power and smaller scale independent
farming is increasingly difficult
thing that we're really focusing on is
looking at food not just feed yeah yeah
I'm not I'm not suggesting that we we
should quit raising corn and soybeans
I'm not saying that at all but it
shouldn't be all we're doing and raising
it for a price that's below production
cost and depending on taxpayers to hold
us up while we see a Brazil's JBS or
China Smithfield or U.S Cargill it's
corporate power around the world has a
lock on it and they push Farmers to
raise corn and soybeans corn and
soybeans corn and soybeans the big
agriculture companies argue that the
huge scale of their operations helps to
mitigate volatility in a complex and
cyclical Market
they point to how they've helped
agriculture to become efficient and U.S
agriculture has become incredibly
efficient just look at how output has
almost tripled in the last 70 years
while inputs have remained the same
so this kind of efficiency is really
what globalization is all about the idea
that companies can move jobs and goods
all around the world and that makes it
ever cheaper for consumers to buy all
types of products and services in the
past Century global trade has not only
grown with exports around 40 times
larger it's grown as a proportion of GDP
but if you look more closely the growth
has mostly benefited Emerging Market
countries like China where cheap Capital
has supported cheap labor and it's the
top one percent in rich countries like
the US who've captured 27 percent of the
growth
that one percent is the asset owning
class in America the people in the C
Suites and on Wall Street who push for
the Outsourcing that lowers costs for
companies and raises share prices but
that concentration of wealth and power
has a tremendous effect on how and what
we Farm
it doesn't matter how good of a
businesswoman or man that you are on the
farm because you have no control over
that market big meat and their feed meat
complex Buddies the cargills adms and
bungees they control the grain trade in
this country I believe economic Justice
was what the fight was always about I
think the one thing that I would love to
see is for governments and policies to
be shaped around
people not industrial AG that's talking
in their ear all the time they have the
money right and a lot of time that that
feeds What policies we create you see it
every day and so we really need to be
working with producers who produce what
I would consider real food not just
commodities
control your money you control your
destiny you know uh the way these large
corporations they control what you plant
when you plant and what you get paid uh
basically that puts them in charge of
everything
so what is that concentration of power
and that efficiency mean in practice
well big companies want cheap corn so
they Lobby the government which provides
subsidies to Farmers in part via
preferential crop insurance
but the corn is not really destined for
your dinner table instead it mostly goes
into cattle feed biofuel like ethanol
and other exports and the sorts of
filler calories that go into fast and
frozen foods
it also means Farmers aren't growing
crops that might be more useful to
society like say fruits and vegetables
instead much of it is imported picked
pre-ripe with fewer nutrients to
withstand the shipping and by the way
U.S consumption of all vegetables Dairy
and fruit is below the recommended
guidelines
also agriculture is already a big
contributor to greenhouse gas emissions
with the concentration on cattle only
worsening the situation oh in
monocultures they're bad for the soil
so this whole system makes big profits
for big agricultural companies which
then plow some of that money back into
more corporate lobbying which just fuels
the entire dysfunctional cycle and so
you've got this system where these
globalized very fragile highly efficient
Supply chains are enriching Wall Street
but starving Main Street and driving
small farmers out of business just
because we can do something as a human
doesn't mean we should government owes
the people in my opinion
we build the economy of a country we
people there's a lot of things happening
behind the scene that they don't want
you to see so they can bring beef in
from Argentina they can cut it up
repackage it now it's product of the USA
that's incredibly deceiving to a
consumer corporations is a good friend
of mine says you know it's it's not a
living thing
right you know it doesn't have a soul to
save or an ass to kick you know their
whole purpose in life is to make all
they can for a shareholder for the
investor
that's why we have to have government
we need safeguards we need safeguards in
place that allow the market to work so
that opportunity exists for people
so President Joe Biden has been making a
lot of the right noises and in July of
2021 he actually signed a very important
executive order that marked a really
profound economic shift away from
consumers and Rising asset prices and
more towards income-led growth and
workers thank you everyone
[Music]
earlier this year he talked specifically
about competition and farming noting
that four big corporations control more
than half of the markets in beef pork
and poultry over the years their grip on
the market is only tightened
and while their profits and prices go up
farmers are getting less
capitalism without competition is in
capitalism it's exploitation
that's what we're seeing in meat and
poultry in those Industries now
small independent farmers and ranchers
are being driven out of business
sometimes businesses that have been
around for Generations Mr McClendon big
act denies abusing its position
cargill's meet operation employs 28 000
people in 19 States we are providing a
consistent food supply and strengthening
the resilience of the food system to
mitigate disruptions we welcome
competition to the industry and support
the Dynamics of a free market
farming has long been an icon of
American politics and when I grew up we
all saw Dorothea Lang's photos of dust
bowl migrants and in the 1980s the Farm
Aid concerts raising money for family
farmers were really big news
but here's some of the bare facts about
farming today
in 2020 U.S farm output was
134.7 billion dollars accounting for 2.6
million jobs or 1.4 percent of U.S
employment
but if you count agriculture food and
related Industries it has a much bigger
impact
1.055 trillion dollars and 19.7 million
full and part-time jobs
Americans spend almost 12 percent of
their household budget on food that
number is biggest for those at the
bottom who are suffering most from food
inflation right now
[Music]
on the next step of my journey I wanted
to talk to experts on globalization
trade and Agriculture and see how the
challenges to the status quo are playing
out at the highest level
what we did for 200 years is we said any
concentration of power any concentration
of control any concentration of capacity
is dangerous it's dangerous politically
dangerous to our personal Liberty so we
use competition policy and a monopoly to
break things up
fishery went on we saw play out in
agriculture the same thing that played
out in other parts of the market which
is faith that markets will solve at all
faith that we can let the big get bigger
the neoliberals came along and they said
there's waste
in competition and what we need to do is
we need to concentrate
all of this production all of this
control in the hands of a few people
because it will allow us to drive down
the price and so you saw over time
gradual deregulation weakening of
antitrust pullback of the of the
Investments That USDA used to provide to
support farmers and ranchers they
revolutionized
the entire structure
of just about every sector
of business on which we depend
so who are they and how did they do this
exactly
[Music]
Lori Wallach blames the creation of the
WTO on the thinking of the Reagan
Thatcher era so on the surface it was
all about free trade but underneath that
it was about the deregulation of markets
so this entire thing
is like some Trojan Horse where
everyone's like trade agreements smart
people are for free trade but like what
was under the hood was an entirely
different agenda they were basically
being handcuffed with these
one-size-fits-all rules so for the first
time ever there would be trade sanctions
if you didn't deregulate services or
broke up a monopoly or sat a floor of
decency of labor standards or
environmental standards or you wanted to
have domestic or local business
procurement preferences this is now a
trade barrier Ronald Reagan comes in and
you couldn't do enough for business
America would be lifted up you know
trickle down give to big big is what we
need don't need regulations we need to
free these companies
foreign
the WTO started up in 1995 but it was a
Democrat Bill Clinton that actually
lobbied for China's entry into the WTO
which happened in 2001. and the way he
sells it is he says listen the future is
about the service sector the future is
about having global rules that actually
bring countries like China into our
system
so economically the case is clear and
compelling
but I would also like to emphasize here
the National Security aspects of this
and the human and political rights
aspects kind of the the final uh nail in
the coffin for Rural America uh and many
Working Families but to them it was kind
of like The Shining Moment of
globalization right so we focused on
trade the WTO World Trade Organization
uh NAFTA doing these big deals uh which
ultimately only Advanced big AG what
would be the reason we would like not be
allowed to ban DDT and other pesticides
coming into our country against our laws
what exactly would be the reason to roll
back by American like what does it have
to do with trade I'm for trade
Lori wasn't the only one raising a red
flag remember all those
anti-globalization anti-wto protests
like this one from Seattle in 1999. what
we had was really kind of The Perfect
Storm for the destruction of Rural
America this this new advancement within
the Democrat Party of the neoliberal it
was this political argument of are you
backwards
are you a protectionist I use someone
stuck in the past the abandonment of
democracy as it existed uh through
economic prosperity and hope of
opportunity that caused this country to
fight both parties abandoned that and
went for globalization and big people
are furious at Big Pharma they're
furious at Big Tech they think their
food system has gone to hell and they
are really mad about feeling
disempowered on a trans-partisan basis
which was one of the worst things that
ever happened
you go to New England you go to Ohio
Pennsylvania you go anywhere you want
secretary Clinton and you will see
Devastation so now you know the public
is struggling to find you know who
represents us out here in Rural America
and Trump was doing his best to make a
broad divide between those elitists sell
you out Working Class People Democrats
versus me the whole thing was like
farcical the guys are walking talking
multinational corporation but he pulled
it off and really through
States like Missouri from purple to just
deep red
so you can draw a direct line between
globalization and the election of Donald
Trump but let's get back to food
security and the debate about efficiency
versus resiliency the development of
these markets have faith and well
extreme efficiency will will solve all
the problems well efficient see that's a
short-term efficiency doesn't respond
well to shocks and surprises and
unexpected pivots if there's any upside
to covid
it's that everyone in this country
actually saw a personally lived
experience the downside
of the hyper globalization regime the
pandemic brought it home this is why we
have to make things this obsession with
single sourcing
hyperglobalized efficiency just in time
supercorporations is simply not reliable
for Supply chains we need more
Diversified production we see
concentration at every level of the food
system that processing at retail at the
level of fertilizer and energy and
people just ripping off the farmer and
ripping off the eater everywhere you
look in America you see a monopolist who
has got us by the neck
so the global financial crisis global
warming covid conflict cyber attacks all
of these things all happening at once
all of them are threats to our food
security
Food Systems today have been optimized
for efficiency and low cost relatively
stable environmental conditions which we
enjoyed for several decades before
climate change really began to take hold
within the last decade or two
and they were optimized for peace time
and globalized trade regimes for a while
it seemed like they had opened a door
into this amazing new world and we could
all make a massive amount of money and
we could all have cheap stuff and then
one day we woke up and we realized the
system that the monopolists had built
was built to fail it was built to break
about 2015 we saw a really consequential
shift from relatively steady gains in
food security to an inflection and from
2015 till now we have seen in fact in
general a trend towards degradation of
food security globally speaking
that's Molly John a world leading expert
on food security we'll come back to her
and all the amazing things she's doing
later but right now I want to head back
to Missouri where all this big thinking
meets the reality on the ground
foreign
and future are sharing the same porch
this is the Schumer Farm where family
farming goes back four generations
[Music]
if you're gonna be anything aside from a
big multinational company trying to do
this like you have to have family or you
have to have a community is that fair
I would say so started some tough times
and just take a lot of hard work to get
to where we're at today and you've been
farming for 75 years started when I was
in high school had a crop of wheat and
had 15 Acres I don't really think I ever
thought about doing anything different
but I had to grow into it I guess and uh
there's no better place to raise a
family or live a life than out here in
God's country
[Music]
life is about more than economics and
economic theory Place matters to people
and these things are not accounted for
in our existing economic models
but I'm interested to know how a recent
commodity boom has helped these farmers
and whether it will keep them locked
into the old way of doing things or help
them transition to something new
I hop on board Wes's tractor as he
plants some beans
they're destined for ADM one of the big
grain corporations Wes says at least
they can provide a stable Market
well obviously we're ecstatic about the
high commodity prices because that's
kind of how we make our living we don't
seem to usually get to enjoy that for
very long so you try to get ahead of it
and I mean by early you know make a move
that you probably wouldn't have made
this year an investment that don't put
it off so they know you've got a little
jingle in your pocket and when the
commodity prices are really good the
guys that sell you the inputs or say the
equipment they want to get their share
of it
the other people that saw the farmers
were going to have more money was
fertilizer companies they just jacked up
the prices we saw fertilizer almost
triple in price the farmer's not getting
that extra money yes Putin invaded
Ukraine and only exasperated this
problem it only made it worse if this
was going on three four months
pre-invasion
food inflation only adds to all the
existing problems already in our
agricultural system so you wouldn't
expect to find food deserts for example
in the middle of farm country but I was
really struck by how little of what's
produced on farms in Missouri actually
ends up on local plates in some cases
Farmers can't even sell to Local Schools
or hospitals without going through big
Financial middlemen hundreds or even
thousands of miles away which seems
incredibly logical kovid showed us how
important local Supply chains are for
food security
environmental resilience and even
nutrition Chelsea's food Hub The Root
Cellar doubled its subscriptions at the
start of the pandemic when we have a
crisis it wasn't the big corporations
who fed its communities right it was a
local food system for example my shelves
never went bare at The Root Cellar I
didn't run out of meat I didn't run out
of produce I was able to supply all the
people who were shopping with me
currently and I was able to exceed that
it made an impact on some people it made
them remember
that I should be supporting the local
folks who are producing the food that I
should be consuming right
Farm to Table it's a movement that was
pioneered on the west coast and our next
stop is San Francisco
I gotta check out apricots these are my
favorite at the Ferry Plaza Farmers
Market Farmers have been selling direct
to Consumers for 30 years they've
figured out how to make it scalable and
affordable I have to eat another one
they're so juicy
they have a whole group of urbanite
servant dwellers who don't understand
where their food is coming from how it's
grown how much work and effort it goes
into it and yet the care that those
Farmers spend on their soil affects
water quality air quality even the
resilience of our food system in the
time of the pandemic where we had
large-scale infrastructure breaking down
supply chain issues and what we really
need to see is a regional local food
economy that can be far more adaptive to
the needs of their community so when
it's localized and smaller it is more
responsive and it is more Nimble and
farmers markets play a key role in that
local food system
foreign
adaptive local markets that's what I
want to find out about because farmers
markets are one thing but we're in San
Francisco the home of high tech so we're
going to meet someone with a more
radical vision
he thinks his company can be the
ultimate in local because instead of
exporting food he is exporting the
environment in which we grow the food
all right let's do this so this is the
farm okay this is our seating area so we
bring in raw materials coconut core we
crush the bricks down into particle
sizes we can use we fill trays here I
want it to be involved in egg
but the price of land was outrageous and
I realized there's no chance that I
could ever Farm traditionally simply
because I couldn't afford to to buy the
land or lease the land as we have fewer
younger people engaging in agriculture
not to be ageist but we have less
Innovation we have less people applying
their brains to the problems that we're
trying to solve and we have an industry
that becomes stagnant that holds still
that doesn't uh that doesn't grow
we have this three-dimensional space you
know imagine a cube a box and we're
doing agriculture inside of this box in
a greenhouse but all of our output is on
a square foot basis I thought that's
weird that's odd why aren't we doing uh
three-dimensional production in
three-dimensional space fresh is the
thing that matters to Consumers so you
look at all these folks and they're
they're all very motivated to have a
stable Supply they're all very motivated
to have stable price they're all very
motivated to have a predictable system
and it's just this continuous Evolution
up the spectrum of control to something
that's more predictable less risky so
the trace will come out of germ and
they'll get loaded into our seedling
system over here so we'll go
stick our heads in there this is kind of
cool the lights there it looks like a an
art gallery
oh wow amazing
so what are you growing right here this
is lettuce and you had to invent some of
the lights and the Plastics and things
like that right no one built lights that
did what we needed them to do for the
the price that we needed them to do it
so we had to design a lot of our own
lighting the sensors we had the design
sensors because no one really built
sensors that did what we needed sensors
to do yeah there are people that say oh
this is really unnatural you're like do
you know how your food is grown now
right uh yeah you go to you go to the
Central Valley and they're flat Sandy
Fields it's been laser leveled with
heavy equipment the reality is like we
live in an unnatural world and it's our
job to exist with as light and impact as
possible on that natural world and
um and to influence the the evolution of
our planet as minimally as possible and
so that's the thing that we solve for
right you know all of that land used to
be full of native species and
butterflies and deer and wonderful
things that you know lived a natural
life uh and it's not that way anymore
it is completely tamed we tilled it over
we dump the carbon in the atmosphere and
now we use that land to serve the cities
to serve the people that consume the
food once this Tower is transplanted it
will roll out so you're going to see it
zip out here
and our pickup robot will swing over see
that big boom arm comes down yeah grabs
the tower and then hangs the whole thing
up
we have globalism which has caused
people all over the world to want the
same things the question is how do you
grow a strawberry in you know Saudi
Arabia or Singapore or these like places
completely unsuited to this very finicky
fruit the answer is well you can't you
can't do it outside in order to give
people the best possible quality and the
best possible price anywhere in the
world in any environment that isn't
suitable for the production of these
products you build an indoor farm and
you import the environment so maybe one
way to think about it is you're
manufacturing ideal growing land that is
a step towards decentralization we're
free to go anywhere we're free to grow
anywhere
foreign
it should be priced at what it can
produce
not with some Wall Street investor
thinks it will produce 50 years from now
is completely divorce from the
productive value of the land and really
what we're doing is kind of the purest
form of land manufacturing where we say
you price the asset at what it can
produce add its value to people right
real value
it just rolls right through and just
gets cut just like that so you see those
spinning blades they just cut the
product right off
foreign
[Music]
we're going to do a taste test of your
various varieties of lettuce so tell us
what what we've got here yeah so we've
got kale arugula our crispy lettuce and
then our mizuna mix down here the bok
choy has kind of this nutty Umami kind
of flavor and then the the mizuna comes
with a little heat okay it's a really
nice Cobble all right let's do that
wow
that literally tastes like you just
picked it out of somebody's Garden which
I guess you did yeah off your wall came
right off probably this morning
[Music]
okay so the kale is um something that
we've worked on for a while and it's a
really nice mild grassy kale some of it
has a very sweet kind of flavor to it
interesting it's actually Milder
than a lot of the kale that
I would buy in my local grocery store so
if we have crops today that don't taste
great they're probably a shadow they're
a version of something that was much
better in the past yeah and so the
question is how do we get back to that
past how do we get back to that uh first
experience with whatever you know kale
was 100 years ago it's so interesting
the idea that you're you know you go
high-tech you go extremely futuristic to
get back to the past in terms of taste
very cool I'm definitely my kids would
for sure eat this
there are some of these risks that uh
you have in the business and you say
well
why do I need a backup generator for a
farm right it's a lot of cost right to
just run this thing once a year but the
catastrophic risk is high enough that
you make the investment when Enough
stars align when enough bad things
happen all at once that the food system
is at risk we will know it and the pain
will be acute I was fascinated by what
Nate had to say but vertical Farms are
still a blip when it comes to
agricultural production and some people
say that their own energy needs are
actually problematic from an emissions
standpoint emissions and costs are
eventually going to come down but the
bottom line is that these Farms aren't
yet a silver bullet
we need something more transformative
and in Wisconsin I found the seeds of it
[Music]
Molly John made her name as a plant
breeder growing new disease-resistant
varieties of fruits and vegetables but
ultimately she wants to make food for
mayor species that grow here anyway this
is melons this is Hannah's Choice named
after my daughter Hannah
is now grown up but when she was little
she could put away a cantaloupe all by
herself
the way in which you're growing here how
would it differ from say you know
traditional farming of vegetables
large-scale fields for example in the
major production areas like Central
Valley in California Florida you would
see much more intensive use of chemical
fertilizers and pesticides and one of
the things that I emphasize throughout
all my breeding programs was disease
resistance by genetically manipulating
you can make it possible to use less of
the chemicals or none or none we find
those plants that are still standing in
the face of that disease and then move
the gene that controls that disease into
a cultivated type usually with bigger
fruit and tastier fruit and then
pesticides are not necessary
[Music]
agriculture is the dominant way human
beings interact with the terrestrial
land mass
and it does tremendous damage to
resources we all depend on climate water
air
and health so it's clear that if we
allow ourselves the concept of a food
system
that the food system we have today
is failing those who depend on it
and it is at the heart of this binge on
energy
that links to climate change links to
water pollution air pollution soil
degradation
modeling her colleagues want to go much
further and use microbes to change the
entire nature of food production and
farming I did this big 180 in my work
from being a natural scientist to really
trying to articulate and frame out the
classes of risk in Food Systems one of
the tricks I learned from the financial
community
is the use of scenarios you create an
extreme plausible scenario nobody had
ever tried to put scenarios together
about risk in a food system so I tried
it isn't just conflict it isn't just
weather it isn't just supply chain
issues it's all of the above there were
some risks that were so large I really
couldn't think of responsible and
effective ways to mitigate those risks
short of Reinventing the food system
Jean-Michel is looking at how to help
plants fertilize themselves without
chemicals
so what are we looking at right here so
what you can see here are all these dots
these are plant cells and inside of the
plant cell they are filled with bacteria
and these bacteria of the B is nitrogen
fixing bacteria that give nitrogen to
the legume and so that's the system that
works in legumes that we would like to
recapitulate in non-legums either are
cereals but also binary crops like
Poplar let me just make sure these guys
here
are bacteria that within this legume
within this plant can actually produce
their own fertilizer absolutely so they
help the plant to grow a true and very
famous symbiosis
[Music]
we spoke to some Farmers American
farmers that were saying they're under
pressure to try and increase their crop
yields because of what's happened in
Ukraine but at the same time the
fertilizer prices are going up so
they're having to decrease what they're
using for fertilizer otherwise they you
know they'll cut into their own profit
margins so could this work circumvent
some of that problem yeah absolutely
that's that's the goal is to be able to
grow crops with fewer fewer chemical
inputs and so here the idea is to use
microbes to replace chemicals is this a
way ultimately to just change the entire
sort of calculus of food water energy
and and how things get grown and what it
takes to do that our agricultural
systems developed in a frame where
energy was considered essentially
unlimited and very cheap so so we have
substituted fossil energy for human
labor animal labor the important thing
to realize about this work is it really
reshapes the energy budget of
Agriculture
when you think of the Tree of Life most
people think of the things we can see
because we're visual creatures but the
vast majority of the world's biology
is invisible it's too small to be seen
and those are microbes and we eat lots
of microbes every day and we are lots of
microbes our bodies are filled with
microbial cells when we domesticated
plants and animals we pulled along lots
of microbes that came with them but we
couldn't see microbes so we didn't
domesticate microbes for direct
consumption
so Molly is also contracted by DARPA the
government's defense Advanced research
project agency to do just that in the
hope that one day we may have gizmos
that you and I can roll into the sun
when the power goes off or you've no
money in your count and they could
produce a micro milkshake or a bar or
pudding on the spot from almost nothing
essentially we're revisiting what humans
did 10 000 years ago
but this time we have microscopes so we
can look at organisms that have
tremendously versatile metabolisms they
can grow off air water and electricity
they create protein fats
starches
and fiber which is what humans need to
eat it's not a big step to imagine that
we would simply grow the microbes
directly for for consumption and our
Dream at DARPA is that no human being
would be greater than a 30-minute walk
from a source of food
and so in some ways this is the ultimate
in de-globalization instead of one
country and a handful of companies
making most of the world's cash crops in
these highly efficient but very fragile
Supply chains you might have a paradigm
in which everyone everywhere can make
food on site locally from almost nothing
this is a long way from where we are now
but economic pendulums tend to swing and
right now the pendulum is swinging away
from globalization and neoliberal
economic models
I'm Webster Davis and I wrote a little
poem about the hollowing out of my
hometown my little poem goes like this
my hometown over balls Missouri went
from being able to support full
family-owned grocery stores
to not being able to support one
well oh well has possibility gone we had
a drugstore now we have to go to Walmart
to get Mom's medicine we had two black
churches now we travel to pray
we had two Feast off now we travel to
buy hay well well has Prosperity gone
one of the most fascinating things that
the neoliberals hold on us they
basically said you know competition
leads to higher prices
and the way they achieve lower prices is
through monopolization
I mean this this is a fantastic lie
a breathtaking lie
so we're in an epic fight we're in an
epic fight between Monopoly and a lot
more Rich diversity of smaller and
competing businesses we're in an epic
fight between shareholders who own stock
and are looking for every quarter to
maximize the profit and stakeholders
we're very fortunate America that we
have the leading agricultural Market in
the world we we want to make sure that
our Farmers ranchers can compete in a
global market but we also recognize the
importance of resiliency here at home
I think you know we don't usually give
ourselves much credit as a species like
we we tend to think that we're a foolish
species we're generally pretty wise
right and so our job now is to make sure
that uh we impact this planet as little
as possible as we grow and develop as a
species as we expand human consciousness
we're not shrinking uh the natural world
we're not destroying the planet that we
live on
America and its ideals that it was
founded on is the greatest country
it's struggling it's struggling to
remember remember its foundation its
foundational values that everyone in the
United States has an opportunity and a
hope for Prosperity we're struggling
because for 40 years we've slowly given
over to the world's largest corporations
all the power
and now government has to wrestle that
back has to wrestle that back in the
name of opportunity and hope and
democracy if we don't we will lose this
country our democracy is on The Chopping
Block there was a tea party I'm not
talking about the political one I'm
talking about when a bunch of business
folks got together and threw the tea in
the water why because England their
country at the time had granted a
monopoly
to the East India Company
and shut out all those little business
tea houses here that's how we started
we've got to wrestle that away we may
need to throw some tea in the water but
we're on the cusp and our very democracy
uh is at stake because you can't grant
that much power economic power
um and and to just a handful of
companies and that's what our
governments do
so we've come to the end of our tour
through America's food system what have
we learned well I think that we've
learned that we're at a pivot point for
40 years we had a system an economic
system in this country that prioritized
efficiency over resilience lower prices
above higher wages and Global above
local
we're rebalancing now and we see that
from antitrust to Monopoly cases being
brought in Washington to scientists that
are experimenting with more sustainable
food production systems and agricultural
methods to high-tech solutions to really
bring local farming that's being done in
places like California to the masses in
vertical Farms all of it is about local
that can be made Global it's about
decentralization versus centralization
and it's about a new sort of economic
system that may bring us to a better
balance between consumption and
production I'm hopeful about what this
means for America and I'm hopeful about
what it means ultimately for the world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the first of a three-part series
of films on globalization so look out
for the next two and please like comment
and share